non me non avete capito cosa vi sto per
dire ma io ve lo dico lo stesso perché
il 24 giugno parto con i video sul
secondo canale che trovate in
descrizione a descrivervi ragazzi c'è
questo tastino bellissimo che non
aspetta altro che essere cliccato lo
trovate in descrizione let's go buona
visione per i video di oggi non mi vedo
che non è stata nota cliccare velocità
le redini a quanto crisi se via
trinciato la sua figlia guardavo hannah
montana da piccolo ci sono dei problemi
da tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono barigelli oggi siamo
felicemente tornati sudar deception che
era uno dei giochi che avevo portato
molto tempo fa hanno aggiornato il gioco
hanno fatto il capitolo ii che non
l'avevo mai fatto quindi let's go il
capitolo ii è fatta in che senso
allora ragazzi capitolo 1 dove c'è la
bocciò la è questo let's go
non lo so se perché l'hanno fatto uscire
gioco completo giocato alla demo quindi
non so fino a che punto siamo arrivati
però diciamo che il gioco è una sorta di
pacman versione horror perché tu devi
devi raccogliere le monelle cose che ci
sono in giro mi scusi
i ragazzi ragazzi buongiorno economia
tra l'altro ragazzi come fatto non fa
paura il fatto è che quando si gira non
si gira meno male non si è girato questo
devo fare qua
tornando sta tornando a ciò aiuto a
posto perfetto grazie perché c'è gente
senza eco siamo partiti misasi ictus
keep del tutorial skip del tutorial
chissenefrega
vamos siamo partiti mai allora vi spiego
come funziona il gioco ragazzi tutto sta
nel riuscire a prendere tutte le gemme
prima di morire è un pac man
solo che c'è un però di tutto questo
casino
il però però vorrei farvelo vedere ma è
meglio non farlo vedere in tutto questo
spero che non riusciva a fare lo
vedevano un attimo che trovo queste però
ragazzi queste parole storco demonio
morto sono scarso faccio schifo
giochiamo a cooking simulator basta ci
sono le vite ovviamente ti riprendi dal
punto che hai lasciato quindi training
te devi riuscire a prendere tutte le
gemme prima che le scimmiette elementa
notoriamente anelka pranzi questo è
quello che prima o poi devi tornare mi
pare all
all'inizio è un casino sto gioco ma è
veramente bello sono 236 lo avrò mai
ecco tanto ieri sento che stanno dietro
di me di sento perché mi puoi sentire
perché c'è un qualcosa di rosso ii forse
ci sono i power up tipo in pac man dove
puoi mangiarti le scimmie l'ho preso
non puoi mangiarti le scimmie puoi solo
vedere dove sono o che ho fatto metà
gemme che salve continuate a fare quello
che state facendo metà gemme è già tanto
ragazzi siamo a 130 martin garics
scimmie si vola non è vero mi hanno
inglobato regata sono morto fra un orto
faro nostro sono fatto tra un altro
trovato nord
porca vacca ne mancavano cento ai
difficilissimo però possiamo provarci
dai let's golf
riproviamoci ragazzi nella demo è
riuscito finirla st parte però era si
tratta si trattava nel 2014 quindi non
so quanto hanno cambiato come come devo
fare per seminarlo aiuto devo fare
veramente un casino prende tutte le m
che adesso vede i nemici li vedo li vedo
ripete li vedo francesco prostituzione
dietro infatti un sacco senza essere mai
morto devo continuare così i ragazzi
sono un problema venisse come te mi
immagino il personaggio che corre con un
ipad in mano che non ha senso però va
bene non so quanto duri l'effetto del di
quello che vi fa vedere in giro però è
veramente utilissimo
e veramente utilissimo piuttosto casinò
devo vedere se riesco a spostare la
webcam dall'altra parte della missio
reso conto che un pochettino copre
l'ipad ci siamo riusciti a spostare lo
fa il giro più volte lo fregato
teoricamente dovrebbero fregato
teoricamente mammamia proprio lui
ho preso l'infarto leggermente dopo
perché da guardandosi camera posto è a
posto ci siamo
raga me ne mancano 44 quanta gente
mamma mia ragazzi orribile li sento mi
stanno mangiando il cervello occhio
giace non poco di cervello lasciatemelo
come li per culla di oggi ho fatto
girare tutto l'anno se perdo mi
schiaffeggio come aveva una vita in più
come la contatta con la morte di prima
con possibile stavolta c'è una vita in
più lo sbaglio vi prego non essere qua
ti prego non essere quanti perché non
essere quasi qua cava cà marta che sfiga
ma non ci voglio credere
mamma mia
10 9 8 7 6
li vedo tutti ti prego non essere
davanti a me ti supplico non è quale
lancio rigore non ci vorrei credere mai
e infatti non c'è a posto devo tornare
all'inizio ce l'ho fatta beh sono morto
però avevo ancora due vite quindi adesso
animare una ma sorge all'inizio
praticamente vinto
teoricamente esatto quindi devo tornare
guardo mai fatto finito vinto vito
schiacciare ho vinto
aprite non avevo vinto basta aprite la
porta canna o chiudi più di lavoro
no ragazzi io vi odio ce l'ho fatta sono
una persona capace o mio dio che anzi a
rivivere e io questa è la voce
che cosa devo fare della mia vita sono
suicidarmi you e skate
grazie a dio o se torna tikwa ciao zio
capitolo cioè questa cosa elementari i
vol
c'è proprio un altro livello che figata
non ti manca regioni da scuola no fanno
cagare benvenuti studenti mamma mia
vade retro satana proprio altro che
studenti
salve però io se fossi in te mele
taglierei le unghie ogni tanto che è
mamma mia ragazzi orribile mamma mia è
una scuola ok siamo partiti siam partiti
ma io non ho più la ipad
io non ho più l'ipad non hockey rekom
celati fa che arriva io non all ipad
aiutatemi raga aiuto non ho non vedo non
so non capisco la mappa cena o major
edibile e veramente orribile senza
l'ipad non beva i sì ma tu sorella
welcome back to school ma anche no dai
romani che estate ragazzi in meno male
che estate divertiti ma sei più ma io
non dormo mai neanche io quando registri
video amico mio
c'è una roba qua e là ai nemici sono
fermi perfetto ma io vorrei veramente
tirare fuori l'ipad che è sparito basta
fatemi ritrovare la ipad no bisogno c'è
un cimitero proiettato
eccolo come ho fatto a contrasto spalle
barra spaziatrice ma cavolo e io
mezz'ora per tirarlo fuori prima che
pirla per un'ora sono stato senza eyepet
fantastico proprio contento let's go
ho preso anche un sacco di roba nel
mentre che non avevo l'ipad sono
orgoglioso di me stesso
mancano un sacco di gemme prova beh
corre il brutto perfetto vai vai vai vai
corri corri corri corri corri corri cori
ciao mi mancano 160 mi sembra era alle
prese tutte ci pensate
no raga devo sfondare quella portali se
non è una porta che si sfondano questa
credo sia probabilmente capirla l'uscita
apriti che quel tizio salve signor
satana ok si è aperta l'altra parte bene
così sfonda a destra va bene però fa mi
aprì la porta per favore la porta alla
porta sfiga ci la porta non posso ho
detto vai vai hanno sfondato vai vai vai
vai mai perfetto
adesso mi sta mostrando il suo vero
potere o la citata ha detto esattamente
questa cosa gori prendere dei sono i
nemici
eccola cioè esattamente dietro
fantastico da quello che volevo sentire
non ho idea di dove siano ok a destra
guarda la si vede un synth e trasportata
a sinistra orribile nov avere un potete
dagli store superpower davvero ragazzi
impossibile se no ci manca solo quello
davvero ci manca solo il teletrasporto
siete orribili sono tutti qua ragazzi
eccola la vedo la vita allora
calmiamoci 432 ne mancano due sono solo
dove uno die non ci credo ecco il ne
vedo uno die dove l'ultimo no raga non
ci voglio credere
no veramente
ecco a sinistra la barriera blu la
direttrice dove l'ultimo ok era questo
che non capivo quindi dovrebbe essere
teoricamente qua seguendo la barriera
più giusta eccolo e adesso che fa muoio
adesso voglio e devo tornare indietro
ce la farò mai no non ci credo a sorella
ma brutta copia de dora l'esploratrice
ma fate una vita senza italia queste
umili ce l'ha fatta
no sì io skate lavoro natio peso di
essere morte orribile ragazzi sta roba è
stata orribile
nonostante questo sono soddisfatto mi
ero dimenticato che ce l'hanno montano
va dietro sono soddisfatto di qualcosa
riuscito a fare per la mia vita mi sia
piaciuto iscrivetevi al canale fatemi
sapere se nel prossimo episodio volete
il capitolo iii che finora è veramente
incredibile sto gioco come veramente
cosa se non è piaciuta documento mi
piace iscrivetevi al canale schiaccia
della campanella che vi arrivano le
notifiche per tutti i leader che come
sempre ci vediamo l'anno prossimo video
beh ragazzi